If you're already sold on progressive
web apps, and you don't need to make
a business case for them,
you can probably skip this video.
But if you need to convince one of those
business decision makers, stay tuned.
The Web is an amazing platform
that has easy access for
developers and users alike.
It's low friction,
provide easy distribution,
offers immediate redeployment and
enables simple AB testing.
When Flipboard launched on the web for
the first time this year,
they reported that their monthly
active users increased by 75%.
On the Web, users can get to
a new site with a single tap.
Apps can be a bit more limited.
In many countries, app installation
happens when you buy the phone.
Three or four apps are side-loaded
at the outset, and that's it.
In other countries,
you may have access to an app store, but
over the air data is expensive and
wi-fi can be difficult to find.
Downloading and updating apps
can be a significant challenge.
Even in North America and Europe,
many users by multiple app
when they get a new phone, then the
purchases trickle off to almost nothing.
When a user clicks on a link in
the browser, they don't have to make any
heavy weight choices up front, and they
don't implicitly sign up for anything.
Progressive web apps, are just websites
that took all the right vitamins.
They add new capabilities, like being
top level in the task switcher, or
on the home screen, and
in the notification tray.
Beyond the Rack, who recently
added push notifications saw
a 72% increase in time spent and a 26%
increase in average spend per visit for
users arriving via push notifications.
And repeat visits went
up by more than 50%.
Flip Cart, India's largest e-commerce
company switched from an app
only strategy to launch Flip Cart Light,
a progressive web app.
63% of Flip Cart Light users
reach the site via 2G network.
So a fast user experience was essential.
To decrease load times Flip Cart
added service workers and
streamlined the site to
help consumers quickly
reach the product they were looking for
by using three times less data.
Users can even continue
to browse categories,
review previous searches, and
view products all while offline.